hi I'm Ryan and I'm gonna be watching
the trailer for the enemy's United Way I
totally did that wrong you're watching
the amazing spider-man 2 trailer but
it's the enemy's United trailer I have
no idea what the trailers about people
started commenting telling me to watch
this awesome trailer everyone psyched
about it and so I'm pretty psyched about
it the amazing spider-man 2 trailer
blows my mind
I love spider-man he's probably my
favorite out of all the superheroes it
wouldn't be the superpower I have though
I won't be able to read people's minds
be so much easier to [ __ ] girls
alright enemies time to unite what do
you do what am i doing I do my life last
time you did it you turned everything
blue and red I was washing the the the
American flag my my flag no one washes a
flag mom even washes the flag anymore
I'm not sure but hey you know what it is
I love about being spider-man everything
oh [ __ ]
you okay yeah I know Costin gives the
white huh max
I don't want your badge ah score look
I'm I'm a nobody
Hey look that your eyes and ears house
must be pretty cool to have the hope or
I'll see you like this amazing
spider-man day Jimmy for sure I wish I
was like it I like to think the
spider-man gets people home oh wow you
got electro music
horizon through that amazing - just
don't destroy him
is really so bad you don't remember me
course I remember you're my eyes it is
Oh what's your name again
oh I do I know it I know it don't tell
me it's first it's a Matt yes how did
you forget me you lied to me no can I
help you let me help you
Peter Parker Arion for you're gonna want
to see it awesome of is gonna be so cool
under surveillance
what is not the question of day we have
plans for you Peter Parker what is the
future we literally can change the world
let's come touch a spider
oh my god the chills are insane my
nipple
oh man nothing is what I thought it was
bigger than you Peter there's no really
so cool now you've got a big prize
Oh
bad into your face it's filthy I was
cleaning the chimney
we have no chimney I love it oh man dude
that was so worth it that's the best
trailer I've ever seen on this show
really called as a show whatever it's a
show to me
that's what counts no that film looks
incredible the they seem like they
really amped up the the tone of it all
that's it is darker like any reboot
remake or sequel it's gonna be darker
and Jamie Foxx looks like he's just
gonna rock it you know I didn't know I
don't know who the hell electro is I'm
not gonna lie I don't and to see that
character he got me really intrigued and
I kind of like that little emotional
hold he has with a Spidey and you know
he's got he's got a black stalker